I've been excited and also dreading to
do this recording yeah because episode
36 apparently I don't over space 6g 36
we've been moving a shakin
we have been shaking and moving booked
and busy this is important I call so
obviously as you can see today's merch
day today is much so merch drops today
unless you are one of our patrons who
guess that episodes early early then
make most of all but for the rest of you
man that commercial today and we've got
the lucky winners of our institutions
have the lucky winners yeah man for you
guys who don't follow us on Instagram we
ran a little giveaway competition in
which yeah a couple people could get
some free [ __ ] so that's gonna be
announced towards the end of this
episode and yeah man I hope you guys if
I can click that link you specially you
especially I'll give you what I do
creative and good as you you especially
puts a lot of work into it man and I
love it I love the merch so much so
hopefully you guys can appreciate what
you've tried to do for you guys so you
know yeah man yeah that drops tomorrow
tomorrow I had a few questions about
today sorry today it drops two jobs
today but yeah like just feel like
context and stuff like yeah it's
something that we obviously wanted to do
from time ago mm-hmm but you only do it
it's a supply and demand kind of thing
yeah of course you only do when people
want you to do it was and I didn't think
anyone would want us to do it for god
knows how long forever to be fair yeah I
didn't think it would be a thing and
then all of a sudden it was just message
after message after message after
message and I was like I'm and obviously
the people want what the people want
everyone mine didn't either view matter
deny defeat so yeah we've sorted out and
initially we were gonna wait until
Coronas completely wiped off the panel
because that slows everything down we
just thought [ __ ] it
we took a leap of faith so we've gone
we've gone ahead and sort it out for you
guys early doors yeah of course that
does come with some downsides in terms
of delivery times so there is a little
bit delay on the delivery times it's not
as sharp as we would like at the minute
but obviously that will get better but
yeah man we're happy yeah thank you for
riding with us man
and thank you for you know pushing us to
keep doing more and more on thank you
for the feedback as well the feedback is
so important and we appreciate that so
much so yeah like I said this this match
is for you guys mum yeah it's working
for you 100 KB you guys love it and yeah
man tell us what you think
young lady you do cop anything make sure
you take a picture tag us we just want
to see him I want to see you spread so
we do appreciate the love oh oh that
reminds me as well me that [ __ ]
reminds me the down side the one down
the one downside whoa
so of course I so annoying so I never
wanted this to happen but unfortunately
[ __ ] happens so for those of you who are
patrons so obviously oh we put the
patreon we plug the patreon non-stop so
for those patrons one of the benefits
that you guys receive is obviously a 50%
discount on the merch unfortunately due
to the need of us have a global provider
and for that to even be cost-effective
in the first place and logistically
possible we had to use a pricier
provider for you guys which means if we
give you a 50% discount it actually cost
us money so unfortunately you're gonna
get your first order at 50% yeah and
that's going to come out of our pocket
because it's our [ __ ] we're coming
yeah we're coming prove what we said
we're going to do so first order you're
going to get you 50% I'll be DMing you
guys your codes in due course but after
that unfortunately anyone coming on to
the patreon now is going to be a three
percent and not 50 but obviously still
get little croissant and song but yeah
anymore for anymore no let's dive
straight and be oh my god
so obviously this week well this past
week has been literally a tale of two
seas it's crazy because everyone knows
what we're talking about well is he
talking about George Floyd's may he rest
in peace may rest in power it's it's
been very very very tough this whole
week in terms of the media obviously the
protests watch obviously everyone has
seen what's happened so I'm really gonna
dive into that I'm really gonna dive
into the video which I've never seen and
I'm I have not seen it now I can't you
haven't seen it I can't watch it
I can't okay let me put it to you this
way
all right go Coco sit there and watch
The Life Drain out of someone hmm like
on my phone yeah yeah then then I
thought I can't imagine being a witness
to that like alive mm-hmm do you know
what I do you know I imagine after that
oh I I can't imagine being the [ __ ]
prick with these me on him actively
taking his life away yes I've watched it
twice it's it's mind-blowing it's it's
mind-blowing it's on video it's a lot
but yeah is the video itself is ten
minutes of hell just for starters is I
don't know man I'm sure the vast
majority people have seen it or not and
if not they already know and I already
knew everything every detail before I
see the video anyway but yeah it's it's
it's a tough and very very sensitive
topic yes just we're gonna have to just
guard we're just gonna have to it's I
know you have a lot to say
it's interesting you know I've been
interested in to do this yeah I've been
excited and also dreading to do this
recording yeah because it takes the fun
out of everything
yeah for what it drains the [ __ ] fun
out of here which is fine sometimes you
sometimes you have to do yeah it's not
all and obviously um yeah it bleeds the
fun out of the situation sometimes
that's just life yeah and
we agree on a lot I know that we're ever
gonna disagree on this of course we're
not gonna disagree on this but I've I
have no idea we haven't spoken back
we've not we speak about everything all
the time and we actually haven't spoken
about whatsoever which is rare for us
all we said was I can't wait to talk
about current affairs yeah yeah we
always speak about everything apart from
the topics that we obviously bring up
here yeah
randomly yeah which just come to mind
even at the time or maybe a day before
and then would bring our because we
think could be funny but yeah we we at
something like this it's just something
we would just talk about and we haven't
even before we decided that we were
going to talk about here we obviously
knew we were gonna talk about here which
is added a little bit of like it's not
that's not us you sure that's not us we
praise you more of a sponsor response
spontaneous yeah yeah do you are but now
it's like kind of premeditated yeah we
don't makes it a bit like I don't know
the word none the word what do you mean
because it's not spontaneous it doesn't
make it authentic true although the
conversation would be authentic because
yeah I know what you mean though but say
your thing say whatever you want to say
I'll give you the platform for as long
as you need it and then I'll say what I
say and then we'll go from there
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna tell you
guys a story and the story isn't my
story so which is which is the first
time in a long time this is happen yeah
yeah it's not my story so I don't want
to [ __ ] up the source I'm gonna read a
word-for-word on Twitter I found this on
Twitter and I bookmarked it especially
for especially for this occasion so
obviously in relation to George Floyd
social honestly also connected to social
media yes remember yes yeah social media
is is great it's crazy how they how
anyone can find you hmm
you know I mean so for context if you do
want to follow this along pause this now
go on if you follow my personal and
Twitter go on it and then just look for
look scroll through my like likes and
whatever
and find the one that says do what y'all
got to do is buy a chick i retweeted and
I liked it and I'm just gonna read her
story and we're gonna go from there
alright so she's I'm gonna meet my phone
by the way cool
she's screenshotted three pictures and
obviously the thing with the thing with
Twitter when they say like do what you
got to do that means they're trying to
find it they're trying to find you and
they will [ __ ] find you so I'm gonna
read out for you so a chick called I'm
not gonna say a name there's a chick
that's put a meme out saying she's going
to hell because there's a picture of
George Floyd with with like annotations
on it so it's got his nose and it's got
his mouth on his whole face and honest
on it it says you're telling me this
[ __ ] could have breathe and it's got
arrow pointed to his nose and arrow
points to his mouth because he's black
he's got big lips and he's got big nose
so that was like the gesture ah and this
is obviously after he had passed yeah
tsunami
so but the lady the lady that post I
think this was on Facebook the lady that
posted this wrote I'm going to hell and
put laughing emojis so this the other
link that's on Twitter is the one I try
to find that so she okay she
screenshotted the Facebook thing the
Facebook meme and then next that
actually screenshot the chicks name that
posted it and then next to that screen
showed where she works and then Twitter
went off like off
it's got 80,000 retweets and 185
thousand likes and I'm not actually
gonna tell you the story so if you keep
scrolling through keep scrolling through
you find out that she actually doesn't
work where this this lady said she works
because she's put so many different
employments on her profile hmm so it's
hard to find her so she went through
about seven different people to find out
where this peer person works and then
she found she found someone in like cave
springs I don't know where that is in
America and I said all apparently she
doesn't work at well thank you for
bringing this our attention kind of
thing but she no longer works every
anymore I think we went through seven or
eight different people to try and find
or seven or eight different
employers to try and find where she
works and just literally nothing I think
up until she found it towards the
tail-end hmm but then someone someone
else made a comment and then retweeted
retweeted the comment saying you can't
you can't disagree it's funny and that
she and then she screen shorted that and
then type said or you think this is a
game because but they found this chick
by the way Twitter found this chick so
it's like this the other guy that
tweeted thinking this this is not a joke
like you can't make jest of people that
die now oh yeah you know I mean that's
why I'm saying that the way social media
is is it's so powerful hmm sometimes for
the wrong reasons
but more times like this for the right
reasons do you know I mean because
obviously it's it's it's it's also
borderline purely because she's given
away information about a lady like she'd
actually has no idea of she doesn't know
so that I was reading through and that
was like the other side of the story cuz
ya know when you were speaking just
exactly I'm glad you but I'm glad you
followed up by saying that yeah because
my follow-up question when you said for
the right reasons my follow-up question
was gonna be in your opinion do you
think it's right that they were posting
where this woman works I feel like I
don't I don't necessarily think it's
right obviously cuz I could that
happened to me I would be like what the
[ __ ] but then again I'm not stupid
enough or I would never even post
something so so what's the word I'm
looking for
what's the word I'm looking for
so if you were the girl if I was that
other chick that posted oh I'm going to
hell but I would never do something
myself in that situation yeah yeah to
get found out like that yeah of course
yeah to get for people to try and fire
yeah so that's why I feel like the lady
that did find this chick there was just
cause does that make sense I agree I
agree that um this is this is not even a
conversation I want to get into yeah
this is a short stop point this is
nothing to do we're very is a good idea
or not good has nothing to
with the whole topic that we're talking
about yeah but I think that I think that
the reason why is it is good
how do I explain it I think it's not a
good idea but not because of what the
intentions of that person are so
obviously the person that's putting out
here Twitter do what you gotta do yeah
wants to know how to find this person
yeah now their intentions of what they
do once they find this person are gonna
be completely different to Twitter
account XYZ 2 1 2 1 3 mm-hmm like 2 1 2
1 3 could murder this girl mm-hmm and I
don't believe she deserves to be
murdered for what she put on Twitter
it's disgusting yeah why don't deserve
think she deserves to die so I think in
in in a cause of like how do I explain
it she does deserve to get outed all for
sure in terms of this is that I think
she deserves to get out in terms of this
is who she is
yeah this is her account mmm like and
people on a social media front and in
her media circles and people that know
her yeah can do that what yeah yeah
whereas when you say this is the person
and they live in this area and they work
at this store that gives anyone within
200 300 miles the opportunity to find
her to find her kill her rape her
wherever wherever yeah um and that's a
lot for a racist mean either it's doing
I'm not underpinning the racist meme oh
yeah it's the most disgusting thing you
can do um but anyway that's my two cents
you carry on no no that that was the
that was the main crux of the story
because I think she's added way more to
because I think I'd book like that three
or four days ago
so she's added so much more so I can't
find like the specific stuff but long
story short she tweeted wait let's find
this game
went through so many different channels
because she didn't have the correct
address or where she worked
found her that's why I found her found
her and there's someone else tweeted way
is funny and she retweeted all quote to
Eve that saying oh you think this is a
game and then found him to [ __ ] so like
you this is crazy how certain events ie
the George Floyd case can bring out
someone's true self
yes I agree do you know I mean because
people for the trucos people for the
true [ __ ] color for instance the Droid
Floyd scenario once he passed away
unfortunately there were a lot of like
there were a lot of other tweets or
Instagram posts or things on snapchat or
things on Twitter that just revealed how
much people are just incoherent to
certain things like they don't
understand how it's it's a it's just an
absolute tragedy yeah yeah people think
but that because people protest black
lives matter that that's all they hear
yeah they think that we just protest
that all the time we wouldn't do it if
black people are getting killed
yeah and that's what people I think fail
to understand the mist and I see a lot
of other tweets or Instagram posts
saying or like Instagram like screen
grabs and recordings and stuff saying I
bought if they just complied then sure
he wouldn't have been yeah he wouldn't
have been killed or it's like do you
guys not even do your research before
you even make that sort of a statement
mm-hmm do you not do you think black
people want to they want to go to jail
do you think they want to be arrested
you think you want to be hassled by
police of course not
2pac was talking this was like obviously
before he died it was like the early
nineties he was saying how people like
my Luther King or whatnot and how we
based the protest and how they used to
protest peacefully and ask for things
peacefully yeah yeah but the majority
still said no yeah and then all right
all right if what if you can't get
that and obviously there is no equality
so they're the minority obviously poor
within a majority yeah so that in then
in steals crime that instills poverty
that instills hatred there's still so
many things so when it gets to a point
where you can no longer stop asking and
saying please and this and that it's
gonna eventually lead to me running up
to your yard and trying to take [ __ ]
mm-hmm like because that was the
mentality then and it's it's it's clear
this it's not evolved since then but
yeah we still protest we still preach we
still ask why and this and please but
police just be like [ __ ] you guys mm-hmm
and it's it's it's just a it's a
telltale mum because I've seen so much
on to it and it's it's hard for me too
it's hard for me to digest because of
the sheer volume of what's going on
because you can't you can't not see us
everywhere yes and it's as good as it is
in terms of the awareness it's crazy
because it shouldn't take something like
this to bring awareness it shouldn't
take something like this to unite us it
shouldn't take something like this to to
show for someone to show their true
colors mmm yeah of course I know it's
deafening as as well as heartbreaking
yeah yeah yeah I human minds like how do
I explain it the week I've had with it
yeah has given me so much stress and
anguish and disappointment and anger and
frustration for multiple different
reasons
yeah and I've not really said it really
to anyone mmm because I don't want to
first of all I don't want to miss you
represent myself okay yeah I don't wanna
misrepresent myself okay because words
always tough okay yeah you can have an
idea in your head and in order to get
out your mouth you can only use the
tools that you know yeah yeah so I don't
I sometimes I don't want to misrepresent
myself
and for perception I think is actually
before I go on to once and say it's
interesting to discuss social media yeah
it's interesting as well exactly what
you've just been saying people's
information or not people's a bit a lot
of people's opinion especially when it's
the mass production of it that we've had
this week or the whole world's had this
week yeah you can only form the opinion
when you win when you allow yourself
like you said it's deafening
yeah and it's in disappointingly so in
some aspects is numbing yeah you can
only form the opinion based on your own
timeline okay you can own me even if you
you want to be individualized it's near
impossible when you can only form the
opinion based on what the people you
follow give it and give you know so what
you see base what you see because I
follow different people to you yeah of
course and obviously I use I don't used
well I only use Instagram so especially
like you on Twitter following the people
you follow I mean it's gonna follow the
people I follow have allowed us to grow
throughout the entire week having a
complete
there's no point meeting a complete
different perspective because it's not
complete different relative at all
there's I've seen it from different
angles maybe we've seen exactly what you
said about true colors yeah I wouldn't
say I've seen people's true colors but I
have been frustrated by a lot of the
people that I follow I don't think is
their fault but I I feel like how do I
explain it I feel disappointed most of
all in a lot and this isn't this isn't
everyone but in a lot of the people that
I follow in where they're my heart's
beating you know actually came the
emotional bias oh it's it's an emotional
topic not where their loyalties lie but
where their efforts lie okay so this is
this is where I could get a lot of stick
for it or whatever but this is where I'm
at mm-hmm so obviously I've watched the
video yeah I've seen the whole thing and
it was
the most archaic carnage ever and it is
is unbelievable room that is just it's
cold-blooded murder in literally broad
daylight or a day later and there's
nothing anyone can do to stop it
mm-hmm without putting their own life at
risk - the Lyonya and it's clear as day
that is obviously for police officers
one of which has taken his life and the
others are standing idly by yeah so it's
just categorical murder that's what it
is it's just murder straight that's what
it is and how do I explain this is aa
man I feel like I'm trying to dumb it
down to make it shorter yeah so I don't
just babble on for ages but I guess I
don't think I have much choice
I feel like there hasn't been enough
emphasis on the incident itself so the
Hat like obviously everyone knows what
happened yeah a lot of people have seen
the video yeah everyone's angry about
the situation yeah but I think a lot of
people have allowed themselves to get
distracted by racism as a whole which
allows distraction from the now
explained so the the fact that I've seen
if we take away race for a minute
I will come back to it if we take away
race for a minute it's a police officer
using his power and abusing his power
into a manner in which he can murder
someone that he clearly hates mm-hmm if
you just look at the facts yeah abuse of
power to take the life of an innocent
person because he can and he knows he
can and he's clearly not scared of the
repercussions that in itself is such um
such a like how do I say it it's such an
issue that needs to be addressed or
how something like that can happen and
because it's clearly a racist hate crime
yeah it allows people who want directly
in like you say in Minneapolis who are
protesting who are feeling it the
hardest who did see it or are related or
anything like that
yeah it allows people who are so
disconnected in England in somewhere
else
that they can use this as a platform to
distract from this crime and flood their
stories flood Instagram flood twitter
with every racist incident that's
happening in the world okay I didn't the
reason that that came to light i without
my own research I didn't even know the
police officer's name until about two
days ago in which I had to find out
myself yeah because when and I'm gonna
I'm gonna wrap it all up this is what I
said I was careful I didn't I was
worried about one saying because if you
cut off the polkas early I could be
distracting from completely war but I
didn't find out the guy's name I
probably saw it in pass in but I want
that guy to suffer every way possible
yeah and throughout the week there's a
there's just been such a disconnect from
that guy suffering to race and racism
and I'm not saying it's nothing to do
racist it has everything just racism
yeah but I feel like in order to make
progress and I'm talking about real real
actual progress yeah like I understand
everyone's angry everyone's upset and
emotional and stuff like that but in my
opinion and this is just my opinion in
order to make real change and real
progress in something as layered as
institutional racism to the point where
someone in an established
when someone has the power to supersede
the law yeah I don't want to see and he
to the point where someone who's been
murdered
yeah I don't at this point that's not
gonna change so like how do I write I am
I think I understand what you trying to
say but you're trying to get words out
so I'm trying to get my words out so in
order so like this is um this is put
perfectly a car I'm associate with names
what's the Trevor Noah yes Trevor Noah
did you watch The Trevor Noah thing that
I did what the 18-minute II yeah and I'm
not seeing him up so so Mason he
discusses he makes a good point about
racism being a domino effect okay and
one thing leads to another which leads
to another which needs to another which
needs to another and then we come back
around and the whole world's angry and
upset yeah because they don't know what
to do mm-hmm which is understandable I
don't know what the [ __ ] to do and that
you think how can we stop this yeah but
the only way to stop a domino effect is
to take out one of the dominoes true so
you need to people need to pull together
and take out one of the dominoes and
this like you just said like it
shouldn't have to take something like
this to happen there's people to come
together and unite well that's true yeah
but it has happened and this is the
opportunity for people to come together
and unite but I feel like outside of
America and certain issues yes we do
come back to the drawing and yes we are
upset about the George Roy Wayne but
it's taken the opportunity for everyone
to flood in every domino that affects
them directly yeah so oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is racist because of this and
this rate is because it's and this is
almost privileged over here this is
someone and exercising their white
privilege over here and this is racism
because this person was crushing me and
this is racist cuz this [ __ ] woman
was choking a dog which is another big
thing which I [ __ ] they're having
this week that I was not happy about but
this is it's I feel like it's scattered
everyone off into every aspect of racism
and racism and I'm not belittling racism
at all but it is such
huge hundred hundred hundred year thing
it's been it's gone on since as long as
races have existed yeah
racism has gone on and as long as racism
is existed it's got out of course race
no races or races as long as racist
races as long as racism has existed
racism has gone up so yeah as long as
races have existed yeah as long as soon
as one race met another race racism has
been a thing and we will be foolish to
believe that it's gonna go in our
lifetime no I know it's not gonna go in
a lot of time but our lifetime is now an
opportunity to make a sufficient change
but we have to be the only way we can do
that is to pull together and come up
with logistical actual processes in
which we can put in place obviously we
can't put anything in place but in terms
of what you said about the protests and
stuff like that
you can't protest racism because that's
never gonna get anyone anywhere general
I mean like you can't you can't hit
things in such a broad spectrum because
nothing will ever change all you can do
is take out one of the dominoes at a
time and eventually the whole thing will
fall over yeah like yeah like you can't
it's just not it and it sucks to say it
yeah it's that like it's not fair you
should be able to click your fingers on
racism because especially in this day
and age where we're living in a world of
equality and stuff like that but it's
such a deeply embedded horrible part of
life yeah that like you just agreed it's
not going to go away in our lifetime so
I believe in my personal opinion it's
our duty to take a tragic event like
this and think okay cool let's we are
angry and we are upset but let's look at
this institution and its racism because
racism isn't an institution racism is in
people that guy that killed him is
racist every police officer is not
racist
yeah um the the unfortunate side of it
is is that there are always going to be
sequences of events that do to this will
things worse in future rather than
better so now think every police
officers racist point included so there
I I don't believe I could speak to a
single black person on the planet right
now who would want to be a police
officer of course not
then then it's never gonna change as
long as that's the mentality why would
it ever change Joe I mean if black
people don't want to be police officers
because police officers are a racist
the police officers will always be
racist and in regards to I saw someone
in regards to another thing was like
which I don't think is I understand out
of people doing that out of frustration
but I don't believe it people understand
the ramifications of what it does is the
is one thing people might disagree with
me wholeheartedly on this but I'm just
gonna say it this is how I feel
the comparison photos have pissed me off
to no end with this week so picture of
George Floyd yeah got pulled over for a
fake check killed then a white arrest
okay got taken to McDonald's big man
unless it's the same officer I don't
want to hear about it because police
officers are not racist police officers
are people and people are racist you
don't put on a badge and become racist
so unless you're showing me the same
person how is like like I unders as I
said I understand people do things in
anger and when you are in angry you
don't think logically mmm-hmm but it's
also the fact that like I said I don't
want to be angry I want to make a change
and making out that every white police
officer as a racist is never gonna make
a change I feel like that's because it's
now become a stereotype exactly isn't
exactly because I think I've said this
to Bella before remind me to bring up a
point about guns stereotypes and I've
said it's the benefit for about a
stereotype so let's say for example like
I said not all police officers are
racist obviously not all police officers
are why we had black Chinese got all
sorts of racist are in the police force
so like you said if it's not the same
officer then we can't categorically
assume it's
racism but in terms of stereotypes if
let's say we will be wearing America
right now we will live in America if I
am running towards her away from a
police officer I'm a black male and the
police officer is white
I think stereotypically if there was a
bunch of white police officers one of
them were instigates something purely
because of my skin color and it's only
because it's a stereotype not necessary
because it's racist because if they see
a white person run in a way a white
person and like the one of the one of
the shoes I have like school shootings
for example are all done by white kids
mmm and they're young and they get taken
away safely do you know I mean they get
taken away they get handcuffed and get
taken away safely like there's no like
well you can say that this person well
this is the thing loads of them get shot
and killed mmm this is the thing this is
what I was saying to you where it was
annoying me is because like oh this kid
arrested got brought to my daughter so
for that he got arrested at his house
loads of the school shooters have been
killed in the school mmm and they're all
white and is that's exactly the point I
was trying to prove that we will never
defeat these stereotypes and this racism
if we ignore a way too it doesn't
benefit anyone like for example like I
said I know I know category I can't tell
you the names and stuff like that but I
know categorically that loads of the
school shooters have been shot by the
police in the school mm-hmm but ignoring
that and taking the one case where he
wasn't and comparing it to a black man
that died isn't ever gonna benefit
anyone that's never gonna benefit anyone
and that's not to say that racism
doesn't happen that's not what I'm
saying what I'm saying is that action
right there does not benefit literally
anyone Bruff anyone what good does it do
it does because it has I don't think it
does any good I think it it adds fuel to
the fire it shouldn't because that
officer it only adds fuel to the fire if
it's the same officer killing another
black man because there's mistreating
people because that's to say in that
regard that's to say that all black
people are treated
unfairly by all police officers you know
if you're using different offices in
different scenarios and different things
like that that's saying this person got
treated nicely because he's white this
person got treated badly because he's
black and any white guy they get shot we
can push to the side any black guy that
gets treated with respect we can push it
aside and let's focus on these two it
doesn't benefit anyone we can't move
forward like that we can't that's never
gonna that's not that's just gonna make
more people angry and people deserve to
be angry but there's enough to be angry
about yeah should I'm saying there's
enough to be angry about and if the only
way you're gonna change especially when
we're talking about what can change in
our lifetime the only way you can change
an institution institutions work from
the ground up the only way you can
change an institution especially
something as big as the police force
there are 800,000 police officers in the
u.s. police force yeah
800,000 so we already know that the
racist part of it is the minority
there's nearly a million of them yeah so
what I'm trying to say is you think when
you say minority give me a minority in
numbers in numbers numbers numbers sorry
yeah in numbers but what I'm trying to
say is the only way you can cut that at
the neck yeah is to push all the [ __ ] to
the top and let it drown out so people
who are racist join like how to explain
it it's twofold
so one you need to empower policemen and
the police not individual not
necessarily individual policemen but you
need to empower the good that the police
is supposed to do rather than only shed
in light on the bad because bad attracts
bad and good attracts good yeah like you
said in today today right now I probably
couldn't pay a black person to become a
police officer unless he wants to make
the change yeah and that's the right
reason to become a police officer
because he wants to make the change and
right now I probably couldn't pay a
white person to be a police officer
because because he doesn't want to deal
with the [ __ ] yeah and that is never
and then the only people that do want to
be police officers a [ __ ] racist so
the more that we shed light on these
negative things
George Floyd needs to have the whole
world only talk about that right now and
only show the faces of the people that
did the deed
don't show me random police officers in
non context perfect example I saw and
I'm not gonna add them or anything like
that but I saw in someone's story the
other day the thing the great thing
about the day the the society in that we
can record all of these unjust acts on
offer everyone's got a camera in there
literally in their pocket every wire so
you gigs perfect examples I drawed for
do you get to record the act yeah and
you get it there's no hide in it yeah
and justice will be served and and if
not then we'll burn the world to the
ground until it is that's the good side
of it the bad side of it
is that you can take anything out of
context and you can spin it the way you
want to spin it so perfect example I saw
someone on my timeline this wasn't even
this week this was like a couple weeks
ago taking examples to remember that
black guy that got tased in front of his
kid or whatever did you see that video
yes yes so black guy got tased by police
black guy got tased by police by two
white officers when he was holding his
little girl yeah completely compliant
yeah yeah completely compliant wasn't
causing a fuss got tased oh right
that's a [ __ ] awful event I want to
see something done about those two
people officers two police officers the
comparison the Irish Road in the next
clip was another police officer in a
white neighborhood yes I think this was
in England yeah surrounded by kids
he had his taser out pointed out one kid
that he was trying to detain that was
about ten other white kids are smashing
bottles at his feet jumping on his car
throwing bricks at him swearing at him
and he was threatening to tase the guy
didn't tase him now the spin that was
put on there was this is white privilege
how was this guy not getting tased big
man the reality of the situation is is
that in that situation he's might be
thinking if I tase this guy I'm gonna
get killed
these guys do not give a [ __ ] about me
and the worst thing I can do right now
is [ __ ] taze their ringleader and try
he's by him his car was getting smashed
up people different bottles and bricks
at him the last thing a sensible human
would do is taste someone why are we
talking about that as a races event when
there are actual races events happening
this is not benefiting anyone like I
want to see specific racist kicked out
of the system so we can uplift the
police force and then finally take out
the Domino yeah but the more we shed
nothing but [ __ ] on police nothing but
[ __ ] then no one good will ever join the
others and this is never gonna go away
but the annoying thing I understand that
but when you see videos like I saw one
this week on Twitter where a couple got
pulled over he was like hella complained
he had his hands up everything handy
behind his back and he got turned round
so he was facing the car and the two
officers were behind him and he was like
you couldn't be more compliant yeah yeah
one of the police officers kicked him
and he was like cuz when it first
started it kind of looked like a a
tutorial on how to detain something yeah
cuz that's the way it look yeah the
video was like two minutes long mmm the
guy kicked him in the back
and he was he turned obviously like what
the [ __ ] because that then instigates a
scuffle yeah and it's with that scoff
with us I presume that police use to
spin or he was avoiding arrest the way I
mean yeah yeah and it's like there was
two officers and it was a man and a
woman and the woman got dragged out of
the car as abla they did I don't know
what the offence was the initial offense
maybe he ran a light or web I don't know
yeah but the fact that he was compliant
is what's annoying to me yeah I agree
with you but what I'm saying is that's a
specific abuse of power mmm show me the
good ones because I know there are that
I know they're out there yep of course
they are but it's like well wait why do
we only have to see the [ __ ] once it's
not necessary we only have to see the
[ __ ] once it's what's broadcasted
no-one's ever I know but no one's ever
gonna sit there and record the police
doing there
because everyone does their job every
single day of their life no one's gonna
record that but the fact is it's clear
injustice that's why it's been recorded
okay perfect so we record the clear
injustice show me the clear injustice
for everyone as well not just the black
people hmm not just the black people
show me every injustice and show me how
the things the only way you can do it is
this what I said is twofold
so the first one is to empower police so
the good people go in and the [ __ ]
people come out of mouth yeah the second
one is figuring out why people who are
attracted to power and attracted to
abusing power in an effort to release
their frustration at black people what
it is it how can we mold the police
system to that doesn't incentivize
people of that nature because someone
like I said about police is people
government is people restaurants are
people everything is people and people
all have once they take off their
uniform everyone goes home and lives
their own life and puts on their races
hat and [ __ ] puts on their hood and
does whatever they want to do like he's
a races at home as he as as a work so
the only way to change that I agree with
you exactly what you said I'm not saying
I don't want to see the injustice that's
not what I'm saying at all I want to see
every single one but as long as we only
show that like you said people don't
want to see people doing their jobs
every day it's not what I want to see
but is what we need to see because it
would not see in it like I said no one
wants to be a police but no one does and
the police are never gonna go away so as
long as it's only the races that are
going in there then that's all we're
gonna get yeah and it sounds stupid I
know it sounds in in a in a world where
everyone is angry yeah it seems like
such a petty thing to say right now
because what you want to say is no
people like no they shouldn't be able to
do that no races shouldn't be joining
the police they're supposed to protect
us they're supposed to do this but as
harsh as it sounds no one ever said the
word is supposed to be fair and it
not and the sooner we sink it in our
chests and allow the her to happen but
acknowledge the fact that the world is
not fair but the only way we can make it
fair is actually make actionable just
causes to change things and the only way
you can change things is doing things
you don't want to do like showing people
being treated fairly like showing boring
videos of people just doing their jobs
correctly it's not what you want to see
but it's what you need to see if you
actually want to make a categorical
change and it's [ __ ] and you answer I
want to see every injustice and I want
to see specific people punished for
their in justices but if I'm only seen
in justice then that's how stereotypes
start and stereotypes cause more
stereotypes which caused more
stereotypes so perfect circle of events
is happening right now the Internet is
flooded with police brutality and
injustice yeah especially white police
officers versus black people yeah so now
let's say I'm a police officer in
Minneapolis I'm a white guy right now
[ __ ] is chaotic yeah I'm already scared
to be a police officer a white police
officer in Minneapolis right now so now
I've just come from a riot where black
people and white people are thrown but
was at me bricks at me I'm not racist
I'm done I'm a normal guy people are -
you're shittin me
calling me names calling me everything
pushing me trying to fight me I'm trying
to arrest people people getting dragged
off of me that's day one two weeks down
the line there's a domestic abuse call
in a suburban neighborhood and stuff
like that I go to check it out there's a
group of black guys angry Bluff so now
they're all together they're angry about
what's happening on in the city right
now they want to say to me or did you
know the guy that killed George fried a
betty was remain in it I bet he was you
may you guys are all [ __ ] racist
they're angry they have every right to
be angry but I'm also scared yeah I
don't know what's gonna happen now these
guys are [ __ ] pissed off and they
have every right to be but they're
pissed off
me now because I'm wearing the badge I
go to do my job
I put asked him to calm down that's not
- assure me no one's hit me but this
thought - Jeremy was angry they start
trashing my car now I'm terrified now
put my taser out now cameras come out
now people are getting aggressive
because they think they have every right
to be angry which they do been the day
I'm a human being
and I'm gonna do what human beings do
and fight-or-flight yeah someone throws
one more bottle that goes past my head
instinctively I tase him the cameras are
on
I'm now the racist cop who tastes the
black guy who didn't know any tags deal
who have no context yeah that video hits
the internet and adds to the pile of
[ __ ] that that people see the injustice
of but it's the people that behind the
camera and the people I can take I can
take any video I can guarantee I can
take any video I want right now I know
how to edit videos but from yeah if I
want to make the police look bad I can I
could take any video I want and turn it
into a racist video but the point I'm
trying to make is is that injustice is
happen way too much way too much and the
fact that we've actually seen something
this week where a police officer took
the life of someone he couldn't deny it
and now he's being charged for murder
and manslaughter that happened because
people stood up and said nah [ __ ] this
this is this can't keep happening and
that is the perfect example of something
that happened that shouldn't happen it
wasn't just black people that were
uprising it was everyone that came
together and said now this is
unacceptable
yeah and now something's gonna happen
and the more you push at that the more
you push it that is where you get change
is where you say okay so how was he even
able to do this I want to see all for
now people needs to focus and I want all
four of them in jail because no one was
doing nothing and then you want to see
what's going on in that department for
people to not be doing anything who was
the guy that did it like where does he
come from where did he go to school
where is he how was he brought up like
why was he and said why did he even join
the police force like you don't stop
pushing it but the more you defin
everyone deaf and everyone with
everything has gone all over the world
but easier it will be to forget because
now
because there's so much going on now all
it takes is before these four guys are
all in jail all it takes is not enough
to happen and we'll leave we'll leave
them and they'll get away with it we'll
leave them we'll move on to the next
thing and then next thing after that and
the next thing I there and nothing will
ever change it's only when we push and
push and push and push and we save we're
not stopping until all four of the men
pen and then we're not going to stop
until we find out what the [ __ ] is going
on in this department and once we find
out the department want to know what's
going on in the state and what's not
know what's gonna in state I want to
know what's going on in the country
because this but the more we got from
this to this to this to this to this to
this to this and then we're moving in
England England England England good
they were moving into Canada Canada
Canada and all these things that happen
in they deserve to be shown but the more
people separate and sprinkle and look
this happens all this now this person
was being races in the gym to me and
this person stopped over here and you're
like whoa whoa okay but do you not think
that the opportunity certain people have
in life obviously negates or tailors to
where they end up so for example Donald
Trump he's obviously a racist like he's
not category he said he's a racist but
in his past everyone knows he's a racist
he's not the president of United States
in Reger he controls the United States
of America people voted for him and they
don't even know his racist hmm you know
I mean yeah and it's like did you see
the tweet Wayne oh yeah he tweeted
saying once the Lewton starts the shoot
and start yeah that's the president yeah
bro of your country is it yeah Trump's
are crazy you might that's the president
imagine imagine if Queen Lizzie tweet
you're done if Queen Elizabeth tweeted
something like that there will be opera
oh yeah but there's not up the reason
there's not a bra for Trump is because
he says [ __ ] like that every day
no but like that's that's not an excuse
inexcusable as your president mm-hmm but
were they gonna do I'm agreeing with you
but he's been doing [ __ ] like this from
day yeah but I know but that that that's
my point when like you said did the
police officer he's been abusing his
power from day mmm because he feels I
can get away with it because he's in a
position he's put himself in a position
where he's gonna take the piss out of
everyone up until he gets caught yeah
and I feel like is exactly the same as
Donald Rock he's at the doughnut shop
was at the highest position in America
that anyone could be mmm and if he's
doing that then of course that everyone
else that has the opportunity to do it
and has a a different dilemma ie being
racist is gonna do it do you know I mean
yeah so it's the only the only thing
that you can do is to attack the
establishment that allows him to be in a
position which he can yeah but keep the
people behind those powers as well or
probably or share similar mindsets
exactly
so exactly is exactly what was talking
about in terms of our lifetime mmm those
people do and Donald Trump is 75 years
old is it
yeah he's old as [ __ ] it's exactly what
I was talking about the only way you're
gonna make a systemic change is to push
all the [ __ ] to the top so that when it
the next generation can have the people
at the top who who are the next Donald
Trump's who were the next and it's
frustrating because that's not how human
beings you want to change now but that's
not this is the thing this is what I've
seen also also racism is taught you're
not born a racist this is true so if for
example Donald Trump would add assume
not necessary to teach his kids to be a
racist but he will teach his kids his
way of life Donald Trump's way of life
hmm and then - so - Donna shops kids
this is normality - the police officers
kids if he has kids I don't know
this is normality I agree in this day
and age I disagree and I'll tell you why
for the exact same reason of social
media in this day and age you don't get
to grow up in a bubble and listen to
just what your mom and dad saying you
don't get it there's a fantastic
documentary about a church in America
where's just a family and for
generations they've been like crazy all
ultra Christians if you will and
basically say that all gays are going to
hell I think you've told me about this
um like um something to do with all the
people in the army are [ __ ] like
[ __ ] and all this and all this more
this and this is how they grown up to
believe but now there's been people from
this family that have been introduced to
sort
in media the parents ban them from
social media they're not allowed it but
obviously they had to have an education
so they're going to school they getting
introduced to social media and then get
a better perspective of what the world
is actually right here and they actually
get to make their own choice and to say
that now my parents are the crazy ones
mmm
this is [ __ ] that I agree with you
parents are still gonna teach their kids
but I agree this is the first time in
history where people actually it can't
be helped be and get your own education
of life the technology forces you to
educate yourself in the right way and
it's it's a case of I understand what
you're saying I understand what everyone
saying in terms of like the people in
the power shouldn't have the power to
dictate these things yeah but the fact
of the matter is that they do yeah so I
can I can agree with you until the cows
come home but agreeing with you isn't
gonna make the change and showing these
people for the pieces of [ __ ] that they
are don't want exactly
Donald Trump is a perfect example
because he's proven he's the most
powerful man in the world and he'll do
we won and I'll say what one and I'll
tweet while one because ain't no no
one's gonna do nothing about it and
clearly the world has to suck sour
grapes and be like [ __ ] you the amount
of protests about Trump in their own
country alone is is endless but
nothing's happening to buy it and like I
said it's like I'm not trying to
undercut anything I'm not trying Pete
I'm not saying people shouldn't be
protesting I'm not saying people
shouldn't be angry and I'm not showing
the saying people shouldn't be sharing
the injustice is that I go around the
world but I also think people should be
making just as much effort to come
together and actually yeah but do you
know sorry it's quite you off so it's
got you off but do you know why it's not
necessarily hard but somewhat impossible
to do because of yes there are a lot of
people that are outed myself as racist
not because of this George Floyd of him
people are categorically being brave
about being races the same racist things
and being like you know what [ __ ] you
guys kind of thing yeah but there are
still millions of undercover races but
they just never want to get brought to
light so when it comes to voting these
are the same people that will vote for
the next racist exactly but you know the
people who aren't racists are
Millennials do you know these people who
don't vote man
so that's why we need to the reason
races get put into power is because the
only people who vote are [ __ ] old
racist as the whole reason we're not in
Europe anymore is because the only
people that vote are old racist people
so I'm saying yeah so it's only when
people this is exactly what I'm saying
in terms of people underestimate the
power of a vote so when people want to
be angry and as soon as they're hot pop
pop pop pop pop pop on to the next thing
on to the next thing they'll furred
they're not they're not gonna forget
about George for a bit he'll out of the
pile and when they've got something else
to be angry about and vote in season
does come around they'll forget that
their vote would have made the
difference to put the next person in
power to make sure that their kids
doesn't happen to their kids it's hard
for human beings to think about their
kids are not themselves it's hard to
accept the situation that they're in and
make a better change for the future so
the kids don't have to deal with it
instead of now because the fact of the
matter is exactly what you're saying is
the people that are voting are vote in
the racist other ones that are voting
because they're the ones that understand
that if I vote for the races the racist
goes and then my racist [ __ ] continues
and then racist cops keeps going and
then all this [ __ ] continues but it's
the people that with the loudest voices
the protesters the rioters the people on
social media they're the most aren't
voting they're the ones aren't actually
governing and voting because they've got
too much social media [ __ ] to complain
about in on vote day they're not
actually getting up and going to the
voting booth and actually writing down
what they think the next person should
be and that's exactly what you're saying
that's just that's the problem it's the
fact that people should be angry about
the system that they're in but also
understand that it's probably not going
to change for a long time
but that doesn't mean you don't get to
make the effort now yeah you still have
to make the effort now to make the
change you don't just get to be angry
for today and move on to tomorrow
because it's just gonna turn into a hype
it's just gonna turn into like like it's
just an opportunity to share racist [ __ ]
and another another big point I'm not
gonna dwell too much more at this point
but another big point about it is that
people are under estimating how to
explain it
stereotypes exactly stereotypes creating
stereotypes people are under estimating
now like they're referring back to
Martin Luther King days Rodney King days
Malcolm X days and stuff like that where
make not many people not many white
people were fighting for the black
people about then of course this is the
first time in history where white people
actually are especially was its George
Floyd thing yeah everyone is everyone is
everyone's on the same side Japanese and
if I can try no no Japanese people are
this is the time to do it this is the
time and a lot of the [ __ ] that I'm
seeing on Instagram on cetera stuff of
that is just people getting angry at the
white people because they don't
understand or they how to explain it
people like it sounds rude I'm really
not trying to be rude but in some
instances with the racism stuff like
that you just have to talk to people
white people are very understanding that
they don't and they know they don't
understand racism yeah they want to
understand and that but they're never
going to understand and the more that we
remind them of that the more we push
them away and for the first time that's
a force of habit I'm not I'm not
peaceful people are pushing them away
because that's a force of habit because
that's just going on from generations of
not getting their help but it's also
important to see what's happening right
in front of your face and for the first
time the entire world black white
Japanese are rule up for the same [ __ ]
and a lot of the stuff I've been singing
is literally just pushing the blue white
people that are on your side I just
getting pushed
I'm just getting pushed to the wayside
like all the riots that happen in right
now a lot of it is like oh obviously
people are like looting target and
smashing up cars and burning buildings
off for that [ __ ] all of that I'm not
going to talk about whether I agree or
disagree with all of that people who do
what people are going to do I'm not even
a talk about that but what I have seen
is that the white people that are
involved in the looting are in there in
the rise the protest yeah not
necessarily just a protest but I can
only like I said I can I'm only privy to
my own timeline yeah so I'm going to be
killed I'm never any comment I've said
in this entire discussion from what
based on what I've seen I'm never gonna
talk for everyone say everyone be laugh
let's [ __ ] [ __ ] because if this
is
I am only going off what I've seen this
is my limited opinion on a podcast
called shit's and gigs so chill out no
people get vexed chill out I'm a nobody
mmm but it's the first time people can
actually embrace and I've seen I saw a
decent mean the other day whereas like
people using their white privilege for
good or whatever and it was like a line
of white women lined up in front of the
black book yes perfect yeah perfect
didn't really like the meme but perfect
that's what I want to see that's the
only positive thing I've seen about the
white people that are involved in the
chaos that's happening in that city
I saw him people spray paint in black
lives matter on the Starbucks it was two
white girls black lives matter on a
Starbucks I spray painting in a city
where the whole town is burning down
they're spray-painting black lives
matter and they got confronted by two
black women saying don't do that I
didn't ask you to do that bearing in
mind the about me understood trashing
[ __ ] cuz I saw it as I'm sorry okay
there's like don't do that yeah
we'll do that if we didn't ask you to do
that and then the white goes obviously
like what I'm trying to support the good
cause like black lives matter cetera
cetera cetera cetera cetera and she was
like yeah but they're gonna blame us for
that so don't do that okay granted you
have a slight point a lot of black
people will get the blame for all the
stuff that's happening because it's a
racially infused war if you will
yeah a lotta black people are gonna get
the blame but in all your anger like try
people try to take a second and say
these people have intention they're not
just out here just trashing [ __ ] for the
sake of it yeah take a second and find
out if they're here for a good cause and
if they are help dumb brav help tell
them what you do want them to do yeah
tell them what how they can help because
the white people they're never gonna
understand and they're open to admitting
they're never going to understand so
they're just follow me on what you're
doing breath and they're just following
what the crowd is doing because they
want to be involved and they want to
help but they don't know how so if
they're doing the wrong [ __ ] tell them
how to do the right [ __ ] yeah don't just
say oh this is perfect white [ __ ]
privilege don't just attack every white
person you see
because you're angry about racism like
take a second take a breath and just be
like come we're going over here come
because it's the people that make the
change like it's pushing pushing white
people away when you sit the first time
in history apart from the [ __ ]
American Civil War there's probably the
first time in history where so many
people of so many races are here for one
cause yeah that bro you tell those girls
to [ __ ] off and that they're gonna and
then the black people are gonna get the
blame for the [ __ ] that they're doing
then come into the next Valley yeah
they're not they don't leave an aorta
they don't leave in [ __ ] all they're
going home is [ __ ] off so when the
[ __ ] treaties come around to get
signed and everyone needs all the
hundred thousand signatures you ain't
getting this and you had the opportunity
to make a serious change a serious
change and it's like anger sometimes
absorbs everything about everyone
it's hard when you're emotional it's
hard to not act on impulse it's damn
near impossible which is why I said at
the beginning what's happening now is
happening now but it's important that
you don't forget what's happening now
take a breath
once the anger subsided and keep pushing
for what matters and not just hopping to
the next thing that you can get angry
about because once you're not angry
about this thing anymore you don't want
to look for more [ __ ] to be angry about
you want to solve this thing
yeah the more we just get angry about
the next the next and next we forget
about the [ __ ] they never got assault we
didn't cross the t's and dot the i's on
George Floyd these three man these extra
three men are still chilling because we
moved on to the next guy but did you see
sorry took a circle back now man that's
fine sir but did you see how I think was
then either the night of or the day
after it might be the night of fact the
amount of police that would protect in
the police officers house did you see
that video now bro it could have been it
could have been and probably had two
police departments what for sex in his
house there were rows and rows and rows
of police officers that's fair enough
protecting ISA that's fair enough and
it's like they've probably arrested more
people that day then they should have
arrested him do you know I mean that's
fair enough
but at the same time is exactly one talk
about context at the same time
protecting their house his house doesn't
mean they're on his side he means that
I'm not saying it doesn't as well this
is the thing I'm not saying one way
already other yeah I'm just you're
saying one side and I'm trying to
reflect with the other regardless if
this is where how I feel or not if a
police officer is protecting someone's
house it doesn't necessarily mean that
they're on their side in it it could
also mean that they are still a police
officer and even if he's a cold-hearted
murderer murderer murderer does not
forget murder and they're not gonna let
him just get mad that's just not how
society runs regardless of what he did
regardless of what he did that's my
house a site once ok flipping that then
that obviously then this is the main
reason why do yell three police officers
need to be taken in because 100 they
wouldn't they saw the murder happen 100
they need to get taken in and it's crazy
because he only got he only got third
degree murder and manslaughter that's
another thing I want to address as well
this is another thing that I think is
important I know a lot of people are
angry about the hearing loss and 3rd
degree murder and manslaughter and not
2nd or 1st 2nd or 1st 1st is my intent
first he was he didn't plan it
he didn't premeditated yeah yeah yeah
this is like another pointing to that
now this is another thing again that I'm
not saying I'm on the side of what I'm
saying it's just another thing I think a
lot of you it's another view and I also
think is another thing that people
aren't privy to and how the legal system
works especially in America so if you
get charged with something mm-hmm you
can't for a specific crime you can't get
charged for something less so if they
taught him for second-degree murder if
they lost and the jury said he was
innocent they can't go down and charge
him for manslaughter he goes how many
walks ok so because this is the factors
as well you need to remember he's a
police officer he might not have a he's
record might be clean
we don't know I mean it's not I was not
it anyway anyway
even whatever he's a police officer for
one and he had three other officers with
him there so the fact that that happened
and obviously whatever sonar whatever
scenario they've spun in their
interviews and all this stuff and due
process and all that stuff it wouldn't
surprise me if it was in the prosecutors
best interest to charge him for
manslaughter in which he's 99 percent
certain that the jury will favor with
him then taken the risk of charging him
for second-degree murder
in which three other people were there
and didn't stop it three other police
officers were there and didn't stop it
convincing a jury that that was
second-degree murder and they might lose
and if they lose then he goes home and
nothing no justice has ever done that
might be the reason why he was charged
with manslaughter and not a
second-degree murder because he's more
likely to go to prison then if they
tried to charge him for murder and they
lose but the because I saw the the
actual transcripts of like everything I
read it like two or three days ago and
if he is charged with that the third
degree in a manslaughter he either gets
ten years in jail or he said and /or
they loved I think twenty thousand
dollars hmm dude I mean and if it was if
it's the or twenty thousand dollars he's
paying that's when he came you know I
mean and it's like to him that we'll
meet that'll probably mean nothing
because he's probably got people on his
side to pay for it yeah maybe not not
like a lot of people like he's probably
has someone that he knows or he's
probably got 20k save or whatever to pay
for his money maybe maybe I think a 20k
or 10k coming which one he was maybe
that's true but that's also an issue
with the legal system and not with an
issue of the crime committed that's an
issue with the legal system in general
the legal system has to apply to
everyone regardless of of what's
happened there there are millions of
cases where people are not in public
opinion people are not serving the time
that they should be serving yeah but
that's it as an issue with the the
American legal system that's not
necessarily an issue with whether he
committed a crime or not and if he's
getting the punishment that he deserves
but also he also needs to live the rest
of his life in fear and again when I'm
saying people need to push with this
until it until it makes a significant
change I think that's a big part of it
as well
I think George Floyd deserves more than
for this guy to get his sentence the
four guys did they get arrested too
they're not and the black community
moves on to the next injustice there's a
there's a like is there's enough energy
and enough source that this is an
opportunity to make a significant change
maybe it won't
maybe I'm completely wrong but it's
definitely more likely than if we get
angry about the injustice that's that
and move on there's nothing wrong with
getting angry about it I was just gonna
say no one it's built in you it's an
emotion that you can't redo exactly not
there's nothing I'm not even saying
people shouldn't be getting angry I'm
saying they should be angry yeah but use
that anger for good you know I'm saying
use the anger for a change forever
because that's people as especially
since people are talking about the the
Martin Luther King days and stuff like
that
that's what it was all about and I feel
like obviously I think the reason why
the rioting started I think they were
gonna protest regardless I think that
the rioting started because he obviously
didn't get arrested or at least taken
into custody
that same night mmm he was he was out
for like two days he was free he was a
free man for a couple days you know I
mean before he got charged or indicted
or whatever the word is mm-hmm so I
think that that in just is itself and
obviously if you're looking at it from
from a from an angry black white or
whether perspective in Minneapolis today
and then you see another video of his
house being guided by an umpteen amount
of police officers that's gonna add fuel
to the fire
Oh 100s it's it's hard to then think of
the right thing to do oh yeah rather
then now we have to [ __ ] you up
because they fun [ __ ] annoying one
hundred hundred one hundred percent and
then but the other side of things that
happens in those situations is did you
see the video of the black guy coming
out there's an old black man his store
got burnt to the ground and he come on
screaming at like protestors I was like
you man have ruined my life yeah you're
angry at the white man so why the [ __ ]
yeah is my livelihood done yeah what did
I do to you man why am i suffering now
because you mana angry at the white man
yeah and I agree with you people when
people are angry and this fuel was fired
they see red and they do she don't care
but what I'm told I'm not even talking
about what's happened I'm talking about
what happens now yeah so like that anger
has happened I'm not saying it's done
but just seen the amount of carnage
that's happened as people start to come
to their senses again the right move
needs to be made the right move needs to
be made I hope so because we're not
gonna we're not going to complete we're
not gonna tick off racism it's not gonna
happen in general the broad spectrum
it's not gonna happen but you can remove
a dom dom in amount of time yeah um but
yeah [ __ ] now that was a that was a
lengthy discussion I wanted let me
double back on the stereotype thing that
was going to speak up yes so me and no
mates and Bella were talking mm-hmm this
was probably a few weeks ago and we've
randomly got into a topic of guns for
example and i said i said i have never
seen nor touched a gun in my entire life
mmm Bella back home she's from Brazil
and has shot a gun before obviously not
to kill anyone obviously but she shot a
gun because I think her father owned the
gun yeah and Nemitz has seen a gun at a
party before like she said she was in
the wrong place at the wrong time she
saw a gun she left but then I said to
them I was like it blew my mind you know
when you have that that light bulb
moment if you line up all three of us
and you have a blind juror and ask who
do you think has shot a gun who do you
think owns our gun the mass majority
will pick me and that's a [ __ ] fact
and that's why I said
it's more stereotypical no it's more I
feel like racism and stereotypes are so
infused because if I let me flip it if I
walk into a room full of white people
I'm automatically gonna think they think
I'm just some [ __ ] black guy and
that's my stereotype true I'm
stereotyping them yeah I don't
necessarily think that yeah what the way
I've lived my life has made me to
believe that that is true do you know I
mean and they could be the nicest people
on earth I don't have no idea I'm like
misspoken to him yeah yeah but it's the
way I view life at times because it's
the way my life has been yeah it's a
view life with with those goggles do you
know I mean here man it's it's a it's
tricky it's tricky and the thing is as
well is also like again James with the
unpopular opinion how do you like in
terms of how the human brain works right
yeah so people get tricked so let's talk
about this people get tricked by fake
[ __ ] that looks real right mm-hmm
so if I had a bouquet of roses yeah
touch to it prick my finger on my phone
right yeah
next bouquet of roses pricked it dawn
dawn this song brings on a fake plastic
one you know I brought my mom I'm not
touching it I can't I don't know the
difference yeah I'm not touching it and
exactly what you said about the the gun
thing who lined up you man who's shotgun
who owns a gun they probably gonna point
to you I've held a gun I've had a gun
pointed at me and I've seen a gun shot
and if you lined up a bunch of white
people a bunch of Asian people and a
black guy and they said which one
pointed the gun at someone and shot the
gun and they pointed the black guy
they'd be right they would be right
because he was it was and that is a far
deeper as to why he is the way is far
deeper in terms of opportunities that
black people
growing up in the lives that they've
been forced to live to put him in that
situation here because the guy who
actually did it granted he's black but
he yeah he's a he's a he's a victim of
his circumstance I think I've known him
since I was a kid I know for a fact he's
a victim of circumstance
I know that for a fact but the facts are
still the facts yeah and it's a hard
it's a hard one in terms of the way
stereotypes work
I [ __ ] hate stereotypes yeah and I'm
a victim of stereotype and I'm
stereotype about the same I stereotype
it's a I don't even mean to stereotype
is an a is built in nature and like in
terms of how society works and how human
beings work you ignore stereotypes the
world will crumble do not saying even
though stereotypes are such a bad thing
mm it perplexes me to begin to wonder of
a world in which you don't base
something based on a stereotype you know
I mean especially in a life-death
situation or especially in an aggressive
situation or something like that yeah
like a lot of stereotype is also gut
instinct and got that's what
stereotyping is really is is feeding on
the information that you've been fed hmm
and like I said like you don't want to
stereotype someone you line up the
people you say which one owns the gun
you don't want to say the black guy but
if someone puts a gun to your head and
says you better pick the [ __ ] right
one big man I'm peeking the black guy
because he he probably is he probably is
and the fact that he's a victim of
circumstance this is again the same
thing in terms of [ __ ] that's never
going to change in our lifetime mm-hmm
the only way we can tackle the
stereotype is if we bring the people out
of the circumstance but okay how do we
how do we how do we get rid of poverty
how do we get rid of inequality how do
we get rid also ease these circumstances
always easy to get rid of poverty is
just people being greedy it's true so
easy
of poverty that's also true so easy I
mean the ve go go go
I was reading something that no me it
sent me on Instagram
she sent me Jeff Bezos is net worth and
all the things you can do with his money
it's worth what is it 80 something
billion 139 billion something like he's
got more money than God yeah
139 billion yeah but if they said if you
bring the ten wealthiest men or women or
ever in America it's all they've almost
got three trillion they've got two point
nine six trillion dollars and they said
if you they can they can eradicate
poverty and still have over a billion
dollars left between them between them
it's true no over a trillion dollars
left sorry mmm and still yeah they have
over a trillion dollars left between
them and that's billions of pounds for
them but they will never do it of course
they will never do it but the thing is
as well this is the tricky part is we're
gonna start [ __ ] with your head how
do you erase poverty and keep capitalism
so the idea of capitalism let's take a
couple cars right yeah the idea of
capitalism the difference between
capitalism socialism right so if we take
capitalism the idea of our podcast let's
say capitalism is essentially
competition yeah so we have this podcast
here of course we want our podcast to be
bigger than other podcasts yeah we want
to do well but we want to do well that's
exactly it
you do things because you want to do
well of course and obviously we love it
and suffer them we pretty much go free
but yeah we want to do well mmm
so let's say five years down the line
we're doing very well we've worked our
[ __ ] tits off for the last five years
and we make X amount of money I know
you're gonna say yeah you come up and
then the Nets the next [ __ ] sing gigs
they're not doing so well hmm so Boris
comes to us and say guys we need you to
give up for you to present your income
to help the bottom ten poker because
they're not doing too well obviously
would say [ __ ] off we've worked our
asses off for this why would I give that
up to them and which we're in every
right to mmm that's capitalism that's
the way that's the world we live in
yes you work hard you compete you reap
the rewards
and same way with your promotions our
work and my promotions I can develop on
work and the more money we're are due
you've worked and the high you've
achieved more money you make
yeah there's is an extreme example in
which they're still gonna be winners and
they're still gonna be rich
but you can't for one it has to be up to
them whether they want to give up their
money and for two also for example Bill
Gates gives up [ __ ] tons of his money
but he gets to choose where he puts his
money as well that might that doesn't
benefit any of us yeah and you can't
force the naught point naught 1% of
people to help the world because in
their opinion the world never helped
them they did it they got their money
they've earned it and regardless whether
they're still gonna be winners at the
end they are the representation of
capitalism capitalism and that's basic
in order for them to take their money to
cure the world we have to say we believe
in capitalism we believe in
competitiveness we believe in hard work
hard work for a long time and reap the
benefits yeah up to a billion and then
once we're at a billion all bets are off
and then it delves into and then once
that's the point that's the head a lot
of people down here will think well
that's fine with me
I'm content with being a billionaire bro
there's so few billionaires in the world
why would why would I not do that but
then you take Jeff Bezos and he's got
hundred and whatever billion billion
nothing 139 billion if he was settled
with a billion where word Amazon P if he
was happy with a billion Amazon would
not be the company that we know and we
use every day Amazon is the most popular
company in the world because and only
because Jeff Bezos is not happy with the
billion so you give up of it you give
you get rid of poverty but we also
disregard innovation because people are
not incentivized to do better once they
hit a billion that's amazing yeah but I
can't earn any more now so I'm not gonna
do any more now yeah you can have Amazon
I don't want any more because I've got
I've literally got all the money I'm
allowed to make yeah so I'm [ __ ]
there's no none none of this next day
delivery [ __ ] prime [ __ ] videos [ __ ]
employing warehouses all over the world
to make sure you get you can get it on
the same day
[ __ ] the app [ __ ] all of it I've got a
billion now I'm done so you remove
capitalism you remove innovation but you
cure poverty for everyone double-edged
sword I guess bro it [ __ ] is and it's
a nightmare isn't it cuz that's never
gonna address that one that's definitely
never gonna change
exactly I don't enjoy explaining that
yeah I don't enjoy that mmm it's [ __ ]
this this there's no way out there's no
way out and then you live in a world
where like North Korea for example yeah
everyone's poor North Korea everyone
knows that but the idea of North Korea
is that no one's poor is that everyone
gets paid the same there is no poverty I
was that's not the case because they
have a ruler who thinks he's a god and
he probably takes everything but the
idea of socialism everyone has the same
thing yeah but when everyone's got the
same thing no one does anything because
what's the point you know I mean bananas
backwards is so backwards but yeah
that's my [ __ ] ran over witness
chicken dinners [ __ ] I forgot about that
let's end on a high sorry please so
today we have we hope you've not made
you laugh this episode but yeah it's
probably the first time and it's gonna
be hopefully the last time we don't make
you laugh it's been it's been an
emotional episode it has but yeah as we
said at the beginning we were we ran a
one-week was it one week we ran a one
week petition yeah for people to have a
chance to win our or some of our merch
and we have chosen a winner
oh we've chosen three minutes cuz we did
say you tagged two friends and then all
three would win something off our
merchandise page user and the winners
are drumroll
forgive me if I'm saying his name wrong
please forgive me mark dot in gay and
gay okay so that's ng e I quietly and
his boys are nacho Nate and hot
chocolate spam we will will tag you in
this video or yeah we're gonna tag you
in this video so you know that you have
one we're gonna message you directly and
then you can from tomorrow pick and
choose which got me one yeah man let us
know what you want and we'll get that
shipped out obviously address all that
[ __ ] yeah we'll get that [ __ ] shipped
out to you as soon as poss and obviously
for everyone else much goes live much
much goes live today
links in the descriptions [ __ ] how
man we're happy and we hope you like it
order as much [ __ ] let us know what
you've got it tagged us all that stuff
let's do a my the [ __ ] man let's
probably like an hour and a half it's
probably our longest one okay I'm here
forever
alright this one's interesting actually
right so I'm a single dad 43 years old
as you know let me start am either
[ __ ] for installing a key logger in
my son's computer so I'm a single dad 43
key loggers a key local where you can
track what keys what what their type in
I'll slap hmm so I'm a single dad 43
years old computer computer programmer
my son let's call him jack he's 17 years
old
is that did you say I didn't say that no
it says it there let's call him jack 17
years old Jack's mom died when he was 10
but thankfully we both handled our grief
together quite well I just want to point
I've read the whole thing and that is
such an irrelevant guilt trip to the
reader
yeah it doesn't add anything to the
story it just makes us want to be here
yeah he just lets us know that I
shouldn't be the [ __ ] because his son
is money
I'm sorry to hear that but nah don't add
it in brough with Jack got his first
laptop five years ago I took my time
explaining how the internet worked the
dangers etc allowed him to create social
media account as long as he allowed me
to check on it
and to know that I could trust him
having never asked for it since then he
allowed me to know where he stored his
account passwords just in case I never
really looked at them so social media
computer activity has been complete
mystery to me the last couple years
however I've always been fearful that he
would try to hide something or get some
get into something dangerous so I
installed a key logger just in case yeah
always thinking about his safety I never
had to use it and the more I watched him
grow up I eventually realized I would
never need to use it
by never bothered to remove it my sister
and I were talking about this in a
casual conversation regarding privacy
and privacy apps and my niece overheard
us they're both the same age Denis and
his son she got offended that I wouldn't
the knees got offended that I would do
such a thing
claiming it was horrible invasion of
Jack's privacy and that I should be
ashamed and the only reason she hasn't
told him was because my sister told us
she'd ground her for meddling in my
parenting thoughts I think it's sticky
because I feel like he's done it out the
best interest of his heart like in it
he's done it for the best interest good
intent good if that's the way I was
turning it out of good intent and he's
also they've also acknowledged that he's
no longer gonna need his part lies no
not gonna look at him blah blah because
he's the son has proven that he's not
gonna [ __ ] about on the Internet yeah he
doesn't need to search you or like look
at his history and blah blah blah hmm
bye it's also I think one of the main
reasons why he did it no I think I think
one of the main reasons why he did
include that wife thing is because he
wants the readers or the viewers to know
that he's doing everything he can do to
make sure his kid is safe yeah as
opposed to just using that on my wife
passed away as I like it guilt yeah yeah
okay yeah I feel like
I don't necessarily feel like he's the
ASSA because if he wanted to view it if
you what you Suns beacon I hate could
yeah he's not doing it yeah he installed
it five years ago when he had the laptop
why his later hmm and he still not look
to it it's just probably something he's
not going rid of because he doesn't know
whether he might need it or not but it's
a safety net just in case he's not gonna
invade his privacy but he would probably
use it if he needed to like to help or
something okay not case in point
an example is have you seen a movie
called I think it's called searching
it's by like the Korean guy Green yeah
yeah yes yes so for those that haven't
seen it it's it's all filmed on external
cameras like cameras off your laptop
cameras off your phone it's not film
like a proper film and its really really
good it's about a dad that searches for
his daughter that's gone missing so he
looked for his he tried to find his
daughter through he's thought his laptop
he didn't have those passwords he had to
find those passes through like example
as well because he's mother pastor and
his wife passed away true so it's I
think it's more of a safety net
this is the [ __ ] plot of search and
in it this is the plot of search they
went on ready found on my the [ __ ]
and this is the blog section I think his
name is John Chow I remember he's the
guy from what's that weed movie he's
from flash Walt flash-forward and he's
from Harold and Kumar he's in he's
definitely four flash-forward like
decade ago um so I think I don't think
he's the US or by I understand the
frustration of the nice yes 100% in that
you how do I explain it
there's always a flip side isn't always
there's because there's always a flip
side because at the end of the day he
wants his son to be safe
mmm but it's on 17 cuz he's basically a
grown man obvious he's not but like he's
gotta be a man soon and you said I
haven't used that whatever but you're
just looking for the excuse to use it
also your son needs to make his own
mistakes and it's based on obviously the
only use it or only step in their suffer
if you've getting into any trouble or if
you're doing stuff that isn't safe but
that's your interpretation of what's
safe and what's not safe yeah
so yeah you kind of need to give people
their freedoms because it's a case of
you might not be the [ __ ] now because
you have nothing but good intentions
yeah but it's not really down to us to
decide if you're there so it's down to
your son because when you when the push
comes to shove and you do have to make
it knowing that you know what he says
because you need to step in yeah
then it's your relationship with your
son that you [ __ ] up mmm so it's up to
you whether your is up to him whether
you're the [ __ ] or not yeah because
it's about how he sees it because in
today's his privacy that's been invaded
so we can say he's not because of this
or he is because of this bad knee the
day if you're willing to risk the
relationship with your son then that's
really down to whether you're the
[ __ ] or not because I categorically
it will because my back could never
coming in blah I've always had I've
always had all your passwords and I've
always had access to your cap something
I've always been able to know exactly
where you said yeah without telling me
that's betrayal that's exactly true
definition of the tree exactly exactly
if you if you don't want to be the
[ __ ] tell your son in it yeah if you
don't want to be the [ __ ]
tell your son you got kilo gonna true
true but yeah rapidly rap rap ET rap